This video is sponsored by Rosetta Stone.
Boa Hancock isn’t one of the most
popular characters in One Piece,
because she is beautiful or because shippers have
taken over the fandom, but because she represents
the core values and themes of the story like
almost no other character. And in this video,
I will tell you exactly what those characteristics
are, how Oda designed Boa Hancock to tie together
some of the most high-stake parts of the story
before, during and after the time skip and why
I believe that the snake princess will return
to the story sooner than we all might think.
On the most superficial level, Boa Hancock is
a character of extremes. When we first meet her
in the story, she appears to be extremely
arrogant, spoiled and cold hearted. After
falling in love with Luffy, this quickly changes
from total disdain to suddenly total devotion,
caring and thinking about nothing but Luffy.
When looking at it from this perspective,
it’s quite easy to understand, why some
people are confused why Hancock enjoys
such popularity in the fandom. After all she seems
to go from saltily cold to clumsily lovestruck,
giving her character an annoying twist, just so
the main character can progress in the story.
Of course the only logical reason why people
like her character then, must be her looks. But
while Hancock has undoubtedly one of the best
visual female designs in the story, her charm
comes form a much more fundamental and emotional
place. Because most of the time, whenever Oda does
something that appears to be questionable to
fans, he usually does so for a deeper reason.
And as so often is the case in One Piece,
the key to understanding her
character lies in her backstory.
As you might remember, one of the big reveals
about Hancock is the mark that is burned on
her back. As a child, she and her two sisters
were abducted by slave traders and sold to the
Tenryubito. Since it’s still a Shounen manga, Oda
only hints at all the horrors that the 3 sisters
must have gone through during their captivity,
but he leaves no doubt that these experiences left
them deeply traumatized. Coming from a nation of
women, this first encounter with the world of men
obviously led to even deeper hatred and rejection
towards any men, than originally was already
the case. But the consequences of this past
reach even deeper. Hancock is characterized
as extremely cruel and cold-hearted. She is
convinced that her beauty is enough to let her
get away with anything she wants. And if that
ever shouldn’t be enough, which it usually is,
she still has her power. Oda caricatures this
literal heartlessness as her kicking puppies
and baby seals, but it’s meant to embody the pain,
vulnerability and insecurity deep inside of her.
For years, Hancock as a slave had to
be fully subservient to her masters,
being treated as nothing but an object.
And so after being freed by Fisher tiger,
it is only natural that she
fully embraced her new freedom,
never to let go of it again. That also means
that accepting or even acknowledging any sort of
help from others is impossible, as it would make
her indebted to that person and give up even the
tiniest bit of control. This is for instance
why she can’t seem to thank elder Nyon. And
yet, the mark of the celestial dragons, that
is burned into her skin, keeps her from truly
being free. She and her sisters are terrified
tho let anyone know about it and serves as a
constant reminder and trigger to their horrific
past. The true irony of her character is,
that while her charm and even her devil
fruit powers seem to be centered around love,
lust and romance, she herself is not able to
love or be loved by others. She isn’t even
able to form any meaningful bonds with her own
people, even though she clearly cares for them
deeply as their Queen. After all she took the
step to become a warlord and join hands with the
very same world government that had caused her so
much pain, just so her people could live in piece.
And so, with the reveal of her backstory,
we suddenly see that all the arrogance and
coldness we had seen form her up to that point
is more than just understandable. We as
the reader, have now gone from hating her,
to feeling empathetic for her. But how then
did that empathy turn into a genuine fondness
for her character? The answer, as mostly is
the case, is her relationship with Luffy.
ハンコックとルフェイの関係はすごく面白くてよく書いたワンピースの部分だと思いますけれどもいろんなふくせんやニュアンスなどは日本語だけで分かれますよ.
Which brings me to the sponsor of todays video.
Rosetta Stone. As you might know I speak three
languages: English, German and Japanese.
Though I’m still very much working on that
last one. I've been studying for over 3 years
and after trying out countless different ways,
the learning technique I personally find most
effective in the end is immersion learning,
where you consume and learn content that native
speakers also use. As naturally as possible,
without getting too stuck in grinding through
endless grammar patterns. And that is exactly
what the Rosetta Stone app is all about. With
more than 250 hours of immersive content,
and using words that native speakers use, you
get to study more effectively. And with the app,
you can basically learn whenever or wherever you
want, so you can finally enjoy your favorite voice
actors without subtitles and get the fine nuances
and many insider jokes of the Japanese language.
So, if you have been planning to learn Japanese,
go check out my link in the description below to
get a great discount on all monthly subscriptions.
Better yet, there is a lifetime subscription
option as well so you can pay only once and
get access to over 20 different languages.
As I extensively discussed in
my character analysis of Luffy,
his biggest trait is his condition-less altruism.
He sees people’s true hearts and pulls them out of
their darkness. For someone who has only known
the cruel, egoistic and dominant world of men,
Luffy’s approach to life shattered her world
view completely. To illustrate this point,
take this scene, which I think is one of
the most important for Hancock’s character.
During the battle in the arena, Luffy covers
her sisters back to prevent her slave mark from
being revealed. His rational was that this
didn’t have anything to do with the fight,
and instead of exploiting her weakness, he
chose to respect his enemy’s emotional weakness.
The past is in the past. Don’t bring it into
present. This act of respect and kindness,
deeply resonated with Hancock. To begin
with, she was already shocked that Luffy had
no lustful feelings towards her and didn’t treat
her like a Queen of beauty, but like a normal
person. And now, he had shown her that one’s
past must not necessarily define one’s present.
Even though Luffy showed Hancock, that just
like her he had the qualities of a king,
he didn’t mind bowing down and pleading for the
life of Margarita, a commoner that he became
friends with. Luffy is a very forgiving person
as he always forgives the mistakes of his crew,
without blinking an eye. Sanji kicked him
in the face until he fell unconscious,
yet he forgave him. He views his crew-mates as
his friends, not his underlings. Boa Hancock,
on the other hand, based on her experience, is
not very forgiving. She expects obedience and she
expects everyone to live up to her expectations.
We see this even with her own sisters.
And yet, as her true self is that of a very kind
and caring person, Luffy’s personality resonated
deeply with her. So deeply, that she has fallen
head over heels for him. Not because Luffy is
strong, but because of what he stands for and
who he is, which is very genuine love. And so
ironically enough, the only person her love powers
won’t work on, is the one person she genuinely
loves. Luffy enables her to show more of her true
and vulnerable self. To from relationships with
her people and to let go of her past and embrace
the future. While loving Boa Hancock can turn you
to stone, Luffy has taken her own stony heart
and brought it back to life, allowing her to
trust and love again. This change of heart, pun
absolutely intended, was so intense for her,
that literally fell ill, being overwhelmed with
emotions that she had surpassed for so long.
And so, what makes it almost impossible for us
not to fall in love with her character in return
is the fact that we went from one extreme to
the other with her. At the beginning, Hancock
gave us one reason after the next to dislike her.
After falling in love with Luffy, she’s basically
giving us reason after reason to like her. She
is the one that helps him get into impel down
to free his brother. She talked to Ace about him,
covering for him, and she gave Luffy the keys to
his handcuffs. And finally, she was the one to
protect him and take him in after Ace’s death
and the events of the time skip. All of this was
neither required nor expected of her and it shows
us, just how genuinely she cares for Luffy with
no ulterior motive. And while some people seem
to dislike this innocent and girly side of her,
those of us with a heart understand that this is
simply the honest side of a traumatized girl that
has started to heal and has fallen in love for the
first time. And that care she has for Luffy and
the willingness to sacrifice everything for him,
is what makes her so popular. Because her love
for Luffy is an extension of ours for him.
Boa Hancock unites all of the core themes and
values of One Piece. Freedom, Love, the cruelness
of the world and most importantly, why Luffy is
the one to change it. And with the abolishment
of the warlord system, her enormous power and her
relationship with Luffy, I think it’s extremely
likely that she will make a re-appearance
very soon. Oda even hinted at her, Sato and
Vivi playing major roles in the story again. So
I think we can all be excited for that. And I
recommend you check out my 2 videos on Luffy’s
character here. Thanks for watching. Peace.